last June Mortal Kombat rebirth came out
people loved it and now we get eight ten
minute episodes of something called
Mortal Kombat legacy which has premiered
so now let's talk about it
[Music]
Mortal Kombat Legacy episode 1 I don't
think I'm gonna do this for all episodes
but is the first one is the premiere
it's worth talking about alright so if
you're a Mortal Kombat fan you saw
Mortal Kombat rebirth and if you're a
Mortal Kombat fan you either loved it or
hated it like it or hate it now we have
the webisode Mortal Kombat legacy and is
it good I actually thought the first
episode was cool it ultimately
concentrates on Jack Sonya and Kano and
someone else that if you're a Battlestar
Galactica fan you're gonna see him
you're gonna be like dude that's awesome
that he's in it and I know exactly who
he plays it's pretty cool I like the guy
I think he's underrated and you see
nothing about the Mortal Kombat
tournament in episode 1 it's ultimately
Sonya and Jack spoiling a weapon
shipment run by Kano to the knose so the
acting was pretty good I like the fact
that I mean it's a webisode it's not on
TV or anything like that so they can say
[ __ ] I mean that's cool they're throwing
down with you know murderers and I would
just imagine f-words would fly there's
not a lot of fighting this like a big
police shootout and Jack's does some CQC
kind of [ __ ] but again we're not in the
tournament yet so it's ultimately a
bunch of like cops thrown down with a
bunch of robbers I found it a little
strange that it's a Mortal Kombat
episode in the least cool part of the
episode was the fighting that is a
little ironic
I was just hyped to see all these
characters it's better than any mortal
kombat movie that's been out it
definitely has a better budget The
Mortal Kombat annihilation if it has a
smaller budget it does not look like it
so by the end you're gonna have 8 10
minute episodes of Mortal Kombat 80
minutes and all solid enough for a start
my only concern is how are they gonna
cram all those characters and show all
their backstories in 80 minutes I mean
they barely did it with this one this
one kind of cuts off and it doesn't cut
off in a moment where you're like dude I
need to see the next one I mean you're
intrigued to see the next episode
because you enjoy the whole thing but if
it left off on this really sweet note
like oh my god I need to see the next
one
like if Kano got his eye just throwing
it out there that would have been
awesome I mean there's a lot I want to
see in here and I don't know that I'm
gonna see it all but hey only time will
tell there's another 7 episodes to go
but in the end if you're a Mortal Kombat
fan you're gonna like it you're gonna
like where they're taking it yeah they
take liberties in it it's not like in
concordance with Mortal Kombat lore and
when you watch Mortal Kombat rebirth
you're like there's no way sector and
Cyrax convenient because there's just
two sci-fi there's cyborgs that's not
realistic but sector and Cyrax are gonna
be in it so I'm glad that they took
liberties but they're not afraid she's
taken it's Mortal Kombat issue Elm as
realistic as Mortal Kombat can get
without being
combat so I put a link below for the
video that's on the machinima youtube
channel check it out come back here
comment below let me know what you think
gotta know what you guys think about
this so yes I am excited I want to see
the rest of the episodes that is a fact
and I want the new game like right now
check out my review of the new game
coming next week she it should be epic
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]